Let's tackle this together. Here we have the rightmost value
of the picture to the left. We'll add ten and then
we translate pic by that amount. That's the statement. Now
we need to do that for all of the pictures. So
I need to add the loop header. I've done that
often enough that my fingers can do it on autopilot. Here
goes. Pretty soon your fingers will be able to do
that too. Let's go and compile, and let's run the program.
Hm, that did not seem to work, now did it? Let's see. The program crashed, and I
am told that there is an ArrayIndexOutOfBoundsException, and the
index that was out of bounds was minus one.
Well, minus one is not a valid array index. And why would I have gotten a minus
one. Oh look at this i is 0, so over here this i is 0 and then the
i minus 1 is 0 minus 1 and that's bad. Now the problem is that when
I am at the zeroth picture, that is the initial picture in this sequence. There
is nothing to the left, so the remedy is to start here. With i equals 1. The
zeroth picture just stays where it was. Picture at index one then gets moved to
the right of the one at index zero, and
that's all great. So in this case, my fingers shouldn't
have been on auto pilot, but I should have thought
through what values for i, I actually want. It's very,
very common in actual programming to get these kinds of
errors. And I wanted to show how it looks like
when you do. Now let's try this. And look at
that, our pictures are finally arranged in a neat sequence.